you were being nice to him so that I'm
part of them was like starting like the
onion was peeling back and he wanted to
like be nice to you but being mean was
his MO
so you were the one who was getting
closest to him in a vulnerable place and
so he needed to [ __ ] kill you
[Music]
so at this Elementary School catholic
school by the way so Catholics no it's
nothing like that uh a teacher was let
go because it was discovered she was an
ollie fans
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny but I don't think
they let teachers go for that anymore
well she was probably secretly doing it
you know and then they found out and
then she's like oh she was secretly
doing something but it wasn't that she
was she was selling drugs to the
students I'm Poshmark uh it was not
quite 21 Jump Street just blowing the
kids Jesus
property sex guys over there huh really
are desensitized with how many stories
come out with these things being so
common yeah we are kind of doing like
the 14th variation of the same type of
thing they found out she was a poor this
is a new one it's new totally new let's
hear it we've never seen this happen at
an elementary school before oh yeah in
this room Frontier okay can't give your
best guess is it illegal uh is it bad or
good it's more unethical than it is
illegal she's physically disciplining
the children because she's Chinese
what grades was it what's a classic
Chinese discipline uh move she's making
them all [ __ ] play piano in there and
hitting them on the hands with rulers oh
she was she was reading them all tarot
cards and then she was telling them
they're all gonna like oh like like you
know die and stuff and then they weren't
really happy I like how you still said
died just like three seconds later die
you know no not Chinese but what grades
are it are they um Elementary so there's
no specific grade sixth or fifth or
whatever okay through six I think I know
Kevin's got a guess too I have no idea
she's helping them cheat on their tests
that's cute
[Laughter]
yeah I think that she's like taking
payments from the kids to get themselves
good grades so they pass or their
parents that's like taking payments from
the parents yeah that's a nice one
Unfortunately they don't get caught
though it's something worse than that
but not as bad as what yeah whatever you
said yeah can
you
so
let's go another round what the [ __ ] you
thought I can you start uh it was uh
bring bring your pet to class day and uh
somebody's uh teacher I don't know bro
let me just tell you so uh she was
flashing the kids oh no dude it's
nothing sexual just unethical she's
eating the school lunches like in Billy
Madison that's pretty funny damn that's
actually really good she becomes best
friends with them that's illegal yeah
that's illegal bro no she um eventually
she had made some comments
to a student when they about
um
about killing herself
she was dumping on them she was
emotionally dumping on them so then the
student told the counselor and then they
they did a little investigation and they
discovered she had a hit list of
students and teachers oh but you know
what I think I just read about this
actually now that you're talking about
this but what's she gonna do it though
sometimes you just need to write names
down on the list because when you Circle
things in an East Bay catalog you're not
gonna buy that [ __ ] it's cathartic when
you're like more great
[Laughter]
but yeah you still can't do that you
still can't uh have a fictional list of
people you want to kill I knew a kid in
middle school that got uh kicked out of
middle school for that I was on a Hit
List in Middle School you were on one I
wasn't on The Hit List though I was on
one and I was nice to the kid too so I
got [ __ ] pissed off and he didn't he
got in trouble but he like was still
able to go to the school but I was like
hella pissed I want to beat his [ __ ]
ass you ever ask him why you made that
no I never talk to the kid after that I
was like [ __ ] this kid you should have
asked him yeah but I was always nice to
him and then like they did The Hit List
and they called me in because he wrote
in alphabetical order and um Alexandria
Acosta so I was the first one on there
so they were like I was like the main
person they were talking to because I
was number one and I was like what the
[ __ ] I still remember the kid's name too
his first name's Cody I won't say his
last name but I'm like bro like what the
[ __ ] I've always been nice to this kid
what was his last name though I don't
know why why do you is there is there
any theory that you can come up with
your head where you're like well I think
every he was like he was kind of like an
outcast but it was was because he was so
mean to everybody it's like he was just
already like mean to everybody that
everybody was like all right [ __ ] this
kid was everybody but I was nice I was
always nice to him I swear how many
people were on that list you know [ __ ]
my eye it's my bad uh was it a lot it
was a lot and there was teachers oh so a
lot of students yeah everybody so what
happened to the kid he got in trouble
but like he was still able to go to
school with us they didn't kick him out
no no I assume
that you were being nice to him so that
part of them was like starting like the
onion was peeling back and he wanted to
like be nice to you but being mean was
his MO
so you're the one who is getting closest
to him in a vulnerable place and so he
needed to [ __ ] kill you
because you're getting too
that's fine he was working there a while
and he was like hey what's up you
remember me and I was just like yeah
yeah I was on your hit list I know I'm
like I was number one on your hit list
so when you paid for your stuff was he
like would you like to join our mailing
list [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah that was weird
but yeah I was part of a hit list that
[ __ ] was wild and then what happened to
the kid that was caught with Hit List at
your school he well he was drawing
pictures of people he was gonna he
wanted to like murder
oh my God this first grade nah this is
like Middle School we were like seventh
or eighth grade but he was like a kid
that got like picked up like he didn't
get well he got picked on a little bit
now it's starting to come to you why he
was crazy but he was also like he was
just mean like he was just he picked
fights with everybody I think one girl
so he deserved the giant wedgie you gave
him I'd bro I was definitely in no
position to be picking on anybody okay
I'll tell you that like at that age I
was like 115 pounds maybe five two you
know so I wasn't picking on anybody but
he was like he was like really into this
girl and this girl rejected him and then
a lot of people made fun of him I didn't
uh and then he just started writing
names down and drawing pictures and then
I love the sincerity of both you guys
talking about these stories about these
troubled kids but both you guys have to
clearly just disclaim like you know I
was being nice to him like everybody's
picking them I wasn't you know I was a
real safe space guys no it's true though
because it's like you know you gotta
clear your name
wow so you guys all had kids in your
schools that were kicked out did you
ever have teachers that were let go
while you're in school for any reason
not until like after I had left high
school for sure yeah in high school yeah
there was a couple coaches that got in
trouble for you know the classic
doing drugs with students and then like
you know that's a classic yeah well I
feel like every story we do is like this
I thought you could say like having sex
with students look at that too and we
had a middle school out there called
Centennial and I didn't go to that one
but a lot of my friends did because when
we went to high school we all kind of
integrated to the same school but he got
like I think he's in prison because of
like child pornography like he was
sending people himself to the kids and
[ __ ] but I used to go pick up my
ex-girlfriend's brothers from there so
like I used to see them all the time we
always wink at you no no but it was just
weird to know and then we had a t uh one
of the security guards from my high
school he was like uh I guess they
caught him in the tennis court hooking
up with one of the students it's like
why you gotta do it on campus
Jesus that happened in my school where
the coach got caught hooking up with a
student and they just moved them to
another school within the conference
what the [ __ ] a little Catholic priests
out there yeah Saint Mary's style you
can't get away actually you probably
could get away with it it nowadays why
are you saying like that you know do you
have a method well it's a different time
though you know what I mean like back
then I feel most people wouldn't believe
students and like it wasn't as prevalent
in the news as opposed to today it's
like super hypersensitive to all that
stuff as they should be because because
back then there was a looming uh feeling
of the adults are always right yeah yeah
oh yeah that's yeah Authority didn't
really have much power in those things
and now it's all adults are wrong until
like proven innocent when they're
already in jail everyone's wrong all the
time
someone is always wrong to someone yeah
basically is what happened so they
kicked her out of the school well yeah
and she's also kind of
um in jail they're yeah because they're
investigating like maybe there's other
things that's happening there that maybe
they don't know about yet dude how did
they know it was a hit list did it say
hit list or was it like actually just
like a Christmas list yeah Clinton
Tarantino that's what it's set up at the
time a Christmas list like I really like
these people I'm planning on giving them
Christmas gifts and it just happens to
be a list that would be
like why tell a little kid I think what
happened it doesn't really say
specifically what happened but the kid
discovered it based on something the
teacher had said
so the teacher obviously was not all
there and might have like said something
out loud and then that prompted an
investigation into a teacher and then
they find this list yeah what if the kid
is making it up oh plants the list there
writes the list puts his name at the top
writes Alex Acosta right but thank you
throws it into the [ __ ] desk it does
the whole thing gets the teacher kicked
out and then she's saddened by it
and then actually acts on the Hitler I
didn't say [ __ ] you said it if that is
true and the kid really did this he's a
little Damian he's gonna have
an
offering
this kid's got potential
[Music]